my parents who raised me or my stepmom
who's the daughter of the American
Revolution and my father who is an
immigrant from Alexandria Egypt and I'd
spent a lot of my summers in Alexandria
with my grandmother who never got to go
to school despite being one of the
wisest people I've ever met
and she made a habit of reminding me
that there was nothing special about me
there was only something special about
my opportunity she'd point out one
cousin and be like you know that was
smarter than you point out to another
one she said that one's is
better-looking than you
point out to a third one that was taller
than you and her point was that you owe
your opportunities a responsibility and
I think you know that that's one of the
best things about being the child of
immigrants is that I know exactly what
opportunities I had because I saw the
contrapositive and so the crazy thing is
that on those trips to Egypt I would
travel about 15 hours and travel about
ten years difference in life expectancy
and I could travel the same 10 year life
expectancy gap in 25 minutes if I were
to leave my suburban Detroit home and
drive to any neighborhood in Detroit and
that always framed why I became a doctor
in the first place the work that I
wanted to do well one of the things in
your story that impressed me the most no
a lot of a very impressive things but so
you're married in New York you're a
professor at Columbia and then you wound
up dropping everything to go back to
Detroit to run the Department of Health
that at that point was really poorly
resourced you know you had to like go
and you had to be apart from your wife
that to me is in many ways the biggest
testament to your spirit of service
because you and I know a lot of people
who came through the meritocracy and had
like the opportunity to teach it and
I've League universities and whatnot and
not many of them do what you did well I
appreciate you saying that I you know
for me that was just that that's the
responsibility I owed the opportunities
that I was given and so it's easy to get
too complex about your your personal
calculations right should I do this
should I do that
but for me that the simple litmus test
is what would my take I think right what
would she say about what I chose to do
and
whether or not it was worthy of the very
unique opportunities that I got and so
that's why I did it I hope that that
focus remains always for me that sense
of dignifying your opportunity because
use is something you talk about quite a
bit in your work and ruin something I
really admired about the clarity of your
run is that at the end of the day you
your privilege is always creating
privilege somewhere you're either
increasing privilege for people who
already have it or you're providing a
modicum for people who don't and like
that's the choice so you know you you
work up the meritocracy you you get you
get knighted by all these institutions
who put their seal of approval on you
and the question you have to ask
yourself is well is what you're doing
you know what the [ __ ] was that for well
well see here's the thing if I say to
someone hey Abdul or dr. twice over
Abdul el Syed goes home to Detroit run
the Department of Health people say ok
like that sounds very like important and
official but I know what the reality is
just like you know what the reality is
where you like show up in Detroit you
have this skeleton crew in the back of
the parking office like the hospital
that used to house it is shuttered your
first task as like the person trying to
increase people's life expectancy is to
deal with a vagrant dog problem because
the freakin dogs are like roaming the
streets of Detroit and I spent a lot of
time in Detroit even I didn't know that
one I was like what like you had a
freaking you know it's like that's like
the official storybook version and then
there's like the real-life version right
and I know what the real-life version
looked like having spent enough time in
that City I was working I was working
probably 110 120 hour weeks I got a
little studio in downtown and I'd be in
the office by 8:00
I'd leave the office by 9:00 or 10:00
and I would do that 6 to 7 days a week
and like the only time that I wasn't
there I was in New York where I would
generally yeah I'd be with saara but
like if she was a she was a resident
physician and so she had weekend hours
and you know I would need to get out and
just keep working because things kept
going there
days where I was like what are we doing
here it's just impossible you're right
like you know you walk in and you've got
five city employees 85 contractors in
the back of the building where people go
to pay parking tickets in the poorest
city in America I'll be honest I you
know I've done a number of things since
but I don't know that I'll ever be as
fulfilled in a job as I was in those
moments at the health department because
it was the thrill of doing something
unique for people who really really
needed it and rarely is work that
unencumbered morally yeah it'd be so
pure you're literally it's like hey I'm
just here to try and make your kid's
life longer and healthier and and one of
the stories I loved in your book is that
you just sort of show up people's
doorsteps on like Friday afternoons
being like hey like what's going on like
what's going wrong in your neighborhood
one of the things that broke my heart
was the fact that you identified that
demolishing buildings in Detroit
actually contributed to an increased
risk of lead poisoning for the kids who
are near the demolished houses because
so Detroit peak population 1.7 million
right current population approximately
six hundred eighty thousand something
along those lines so the thing is almost
two-thirds empty so you look around and
the way Detroit's laid out is that it's
a fairly large area it's not like Isla
Manhattan it's like super densely
populated it's like fairly spread out
it's huge you could fit all of Boston
Manhattan in San Francisco and Detroit
and still have room left over yeah yeah
so it's kind of spread out and it's
almost two-thirds empty so you have all
these buildings that are derelict
hazardous blighted so the fact that they
were trying to demolish them I was for
the fact that unfortunately the building
materials had led paint on them such
that if you demolish and let dust goes
up and probably ends up increasing
health risks for people for blocks
around particularly vulnerable kids I
was like oh no I got it's like real
sinking feeling and the fact you
identified that you know to me was so
profound
because I know the people in charge were
very excited about demolishing some
buildings and that's the thing the
demolitions weren't the problem when you
demolish at that scale it's almost
impossible to hold all of the
contractors who are actually doing the
demolishing accountable and so you know
of course they're going to cut corners
and they're going to cheat and when they
do that means that the lead that was you
know packed away in the inside of those
homes gets out and you know you got a
kid playing outside or a kid opening the
window and trying to study in the room
that's gonna get in their lungs and that
has consequences and unfortunately when
we analyzed it that's what we found and
so it was really frustrating right
because you know this is a high profile
program a program that has a lot of
money going into it and you know nobody
wants to hear bad news but this sort of
gets to the beginning of the
conversation that we had
Andrew which is in public health the
hard part about public health is not if
you're allowed and you ring the alarm
bells right people are like yeah this is
it's not a big deal
right it's gonna be just fine and if
you're quiet then bad things happen and
so you're constantly fighting a losing
battle and here we are in the middle of
a corona virus pandemic that really is
the same story Alex a czar for all of
the things I disagree with him on there
I tried to turning the alarm bells about
this pandemic well before it became a
global pandemic and they shouted him
down right they shush them up and here
we are and so you know I know that
experience right I literally got called
Cassandra by the higher-ups in the
office because every time I'd come in
I'd be like look I've got bad news for
you and let me tell you how this is
gonna hurt kids and they'd be like well
you know yeah well
[Music]